Y
SURE ANYBODY IS TAKING HIS
ADVICE.
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS THE FORMER
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT AND
AUTHOR OF "HERE'S THE DEAL."
CLINTONS ARE BACK, BABY, JUST
GRAB YOUR WALLET.
>> OH, BOY, BILL CLINTON WAS
SUCH AN INTERESTING PERSON.
PEOPLE REALLY WANTED TO HEAR
HIM, LISTEN TO HIM.
HE WAS THE COME BACK KID WHO
CAME IN THIRD IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
AND SOMEHOW SAID I'M THE COME
BACK KID JUST WATCH ME AND GOT
THE NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE.
JESSE, HERE IS THE GUY WHO
REALLY RAN SUCCESSFULLY UNDER
THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL.
WHAT IS IT?
WELL IT DISBANDED IN 2011 AND
GONE FOR A LONG TIME.
HERE IS WHY IT.
REPRESENTED THE MORE CENTRIST
MODERATE PART OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
BILL CLINTON WHO CALLED SUPER
PREDATORS BILL CLINTON SIGNED IN
WELFARE REFORM AGAINST GAY
MIRAGE, ABORTION SHOULD BE RARE.
THAT PART OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS NO MORE.
WHY IS THIS RELEVANT?
IT'S RELEVANT BECAUSE IF I WERE
BILL CLINTON THE STATESMAN I
WOULD TRY TO GET MY PARTY SO OUT
OF SYNC AND TOUCH WITH AMERICA I
WOULD BE TRYING TO GET THEM TO
THE CENTER.
INSTEAD REDUCED TO YOU
SOUNDBITES AND PLATITUDES
THEBACK-TO-BACK JOE BIDEN BILL
CLINTON INTERVIEWS THIS WEEKEND
WERE PUFF AND FLUFF.
WE DIDN'T GET A LOT OF STUFF OUT
OF EITHER OF THEM.
REGRETTABLE FOR BILL CLINTON TWO
TERM PRESIDENT PEOPLE LOOK
TOWARD HULK RELIEF IN HAITI OR
BRINGING HOSTAGES HOME.
HELPING WITH AIDES RELIEF AND
HIV CURES.
AND, YOU KNOW, HE WAKES UP EVERY
MORNING AND HE IS AT LEAST THE
MOST POPULAR PERSON IN THE YOU
KNOW WHO THE SECOND MOST POPULAR
PERSON THERE.
THAT ASIDE, YOU KNOW, HILLARY
CLINTON IS THE ONE THAT HAS
ALWAYS GOTTEN MY GOAT.
SOMEONE KELLYANNE SHE IS
SUCCESSFUL IN HER RIGHT FOLK
WOULDN'T KNOW WHO WAS EXCEPT FOR
THROUGH HIM.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT SHE IS DOING
RIGHT NOW, SHE AND HERS
DAUGHERTY OUT DOING GUTSY HOW
GUTSY THEY ARE AND OTHER WOMEN
ARE HOW ABOUT THE FIRST LADY OF
UKRAINE.
HOW ABOUT SOME OF THESE SINGLE
MOMS WORKING TWO AND THREE JOBS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS THE
FASTEST NEW GROUP OF HOMELESS IN
OUR COUNTRY.
HOW ABOUT REAL GUTSY PEOPLE OUT
THERE?
>> Jesse: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
BRINGS ME TO SAY SOMETHING
KELLYANNE?
WHILE AREN'T THEY OUT TALKING TO
THE MIGRANT FAMILIES WHO ARE
SUFFERING?
WHY AREN'T THEY OUT THERE WITH
MOMS?
>> GUTSY.
>> Jesse: MOMS WHO CAN'T FIND
BABY FORMULA OR CAN'T AFFORD
GROCERIES?
WHERE ARE THEY ON THESE ISSUES?
MASSIVE HOMELESSNESS, WOMEN
GETTING SHOVED INTO SUBWAY
TRACKS AND CAN'T EVEN FIND THE
CLINTONS, ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY
SHOW UP IN NEW YORK CITY WITH
THEIR HANDS.
DO YOU FIND THE TIMING
INTERESTING THAT AFTER SHE LOST
THE ELECTION THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION JUST DRIES UP?
NO ONE WANTS TO DONATE ANYMORE
IN THE MINUTE JOE BIDEN BASICRY
SAYS I MIGHT NOT RUN ANYMORE?
OH, THE CLINTONS ARE BACK AND
THEY ARE ASKING FOR MORE MONEY
INTERESTING TIMING?
>> I THINK IT'S APPALLING TIMING
IN THIS WAY, I THINK THE TIME TO
GET THE CLINTON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE UP AND RUNNING AFTER
SHE LOST THE SECOND TIME.
AFTER SHE LOST TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN 2016.
SHE SHOULD HAVE SAID LISTEN, I'M
GOING TO DUST MYSELF OFF
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT, NOT
LEAVING MY OWN HEAD AND BITTER
AND SCOWLING AND SUCKING ON
LEMONS FOR SIX YEARS.
LET'S DO THE CLINTON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE TOGETHER, BILL, I'M
GOING TO HAVE THE HILLARY
CLINTON CENTER FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS.
HEM WOMEN AROUND THE GLOBE AND
HELP WITH EDUCATION, WITH
DISEASE, WITH HOMELESSNESS HERE
AND ALL OF THAT THE OPIOID
CRISIS, I NEVER HEARD FROM HER
WHEN WE WERE DOING THAT
SUCCESSFULLY.
IN THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
AND THIS IS, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY
WOULD JOKE OH, THERE IS A BILL
CLINTON CENTER FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS.
BUT THE THAT ASIDE.
THERE SHOULD BE A HILLARY
CLINTON CENTER FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS.
SHE HAS NEVER DONE ANYTHING FOR
ANYONE ELSE OF THAT MEASURE,
TAKEN THE MAGNITUDE OF HER REACH
AND, YOU KNOW, TWO FAILED
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNS DOESN'T
COUNT.
WHAT DO YOU IS YOU SAY LOOK,
THAT WASN'T MY TIME.
GOD HAD A DIFFERENT PLAN FOR ME.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
$250 MILLION AND MUTT IT TO GOOD
USE FOR OTHERS.
SHE HASN'T SAID A WORD I'M SURE,
A WORD TO HELP THE MIGRANTS, I'M
SURE INTO IS JUST THERE
CRITICIZING OTHERS.
VERY BIG ON THE WORLD STAGE FOR
A LONG TIME AND I HOPE THEY CAN
DO WELL BY DOING GOOD BUT I JUST
DON'T SEE IT.
I WOULD LIKE THEM TO DO MORE FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
FOCUS ON AMERICA JUST FOR ONCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.